here done some really nice book he's
actually presented today welcome thank
you okay
hello everyone today I am going to talk
about the application of machine
learning for glaucoma using EHR data in
the beginning I will thank you for my
advisor my gaming show and my committee
I Incheon and all my coworker in our
research team and our department demise
and our study was founded by an air
entraining Graham here is the ally for
today presentation we will start from
what is glaucoma and important for the
risk prediction and the progression
prediction of glaucoma and explored the
machine learning application in glaucoma
and our approach for the prediction
model of glaucoma and then we will talk
about the research question and our
potential projects so what is glaucoma
glaucoma is a group of eye disease
characterized by progressive
degeneration of optic nerve and the
visual field lost that are irreversible
in addition glaucoma can lead to blight
you River irreversible blindness in this
presentation or study we will focus on
the open angle glaucoma which the which
is the most common form of glaucoma
about 95%
the figures here shows the mechanism of
glaucoma left side is the normal anatomy
of eye we can see the etiquettes humor
will outflow from the trabecular
meshwork but in glaucoma patients the
trabecular meshwork was blocking and the
adequate outflow decrease in the
resistance increased so that will
increase the intraocular pressure and
then for long term that can damage to
the optic nerve here so the coma is the
second leading cause of blindness in the
world and we just say that the vision
loss and the damage to the optic nerve
is irreversible there about fifty seven
and half million people in the world had
a glaucoma in 2015 and this number is
still increasing in u.s. there's about
two and 2.8 million people had a
glaucoma at open-angle glaucoma in 2010
the currently the prevalence of
open-angle glaucoma in you as is about
1.9 percent for the population older
than 40 years old
there are several clinical examination
and has can help position to make
diagnosis of coma include a intraocular
pressure the feature film function that
can measure by the visual field loss
this is the visual field test and
there's some damage to the optic nerve
of or the retinal structure change and
some image device can use to make sure
the like the original nerve fiber layers
can measure by the OCT that could be a
useful tools for improve the diagnosis
however for the coma there are no single
go standard tool can make the diagnosis
there are the good treatment glaucoma
include medication
sir in the conventional surgery the
medication included topical medication
and eyedrops the goal of medication if
one is to increase the outflow of the
adequate humor or reduce the production
and both the laser surgery and a
conventional surgery surgery was trying
to increase the outflow trabeculectomy
is the most common sorry it's the most
common conventional surgery
it might remove part of the part of the
trabecular meshwork also we have several
a clinical examination tool to help to
attack no static or coma open angle
glaucoma develop very slowly over time
with our pen sensation and the the the
laking of clear stinking the only Seiken
find it it's like gradually progressive
of visual field loss and stuff from the
peripheral field so this is very
important for the screening of coma or
make prediction of the grip patient risk
develop glaucoma so currently the most
popular use prediction model in clinical
it's come from 231 is ocular
hypertension treatment study and the
European looked coma Prevention's 30
which man as a star score system is a
massive forest amazing the five-year
risk that an individual with ocular
hypertension will develop develop
primary open-angle glaucoma here is the
equation of the prediction model we can
find this Massa include age and several
clinical interests like vertical cut ask
ratio intra ocular hypertension
intraocular pressure and the central
cornea thickness and the visual field
pattern standard deviation however for
the diabetes
it's it's still controversial in the
ocular hypertension treatment 30 they
found that diabetes is a protective
factor for glaucoma but in this study
they did not include a participant with
retinopathy and this finding is a
controversial for some other study so in
many clinical tool for predictor Wisc of
glaucoma did not include a diabetes the
the scores the scores a star score was
external validate from several study and
a pretty convenient used in the clinical
setting but there's still some
limitation of this tool this model does
not include other major risk factors
such as the race or the family history
actually in the European study older
participant are Caucasian and they did
not recall any family history
information so here glaucoma is a multi
risk factor disease so here is the list
of possible risk factor of the onset of
coma include age gender race family
history of glaucoma or the label of
intraocular pressure the myopia type 2
diabetes the hypertension or
hypertension vasospasm and some distinct
central cornea so the second limitation
of this of this model is the model used
only the baseline nature of the
predictors we can we still remember
about include age and several are
examined me examination majors but
liking accounting for the change of
fluctuation of this predictors
particularly for the intraocular
pressure is a pretty important risk
factor of glaucoma prognosis and in
addition the model used only for patient
with untreated ocular hypertension but
about 50% accommodation it's normal
tension that means there in
ocular pressure is not elevated and this
model cannot use the information from
after patients started glaucoma
treatment so other than the risk
protection of go coma glaucoma
progression is another important issues
this figure shows the progression of
coma is very different amount different
patients the lie a is a just show the
patient of that the vision function
decrease amount age and the lie be and
lightly shows the with similar symptom
patient's diagnosis of glaucoma at
different ages if the patient is younger
than the progress by worse and that the
line is shows some patients just have
very worse or progression of Gotama so
this the this difference between the
glaucoma patient of the progression
makes it's more difficult to make the
prediction of the glaucoma prognosis and
we as we see the Kakuma has a multi
factor and a very complex disease so
this complexity make the disease it's
even more hard to make their prediction
and based on the literature review the
previous 34 the progression prediction
model mainly use one or two clinical
feature like visual field change or
change of intraocular pressure they try
to use like finger or to make sure to
make the like short use use shortened
being sure to make the long-term
prediction however the this similar
situation is many risk factor are not
considered or include in this prediction
model so um as the laking goat standard
to over the glaucoma daikon diagnosis
and medical data of go coma it's a high
complexity and a high dimensional so
many study try to
immersion learning Massa it could be it
might be a good way to handle this kind
of high dimensional data to improve the
diagnosis or progression prediction of
the coma management based on the
literature review paper this the most
previous published 30 in the coma use
the image data for improved the
diagnosis this paper is review article
published in British Journal autumn
ology in this year and there are about
thirty a study mainly used the image
data and the functional data such as
visual feel change to improve the
document management and certain ones
thirty folks are improved diagnosis and
only six thirty focus on improve the
prediction of prognosis and only one
study try to predict need for this
surgery of glaucoma patients used EHR
data so as we mentioned that there are
many risk factor of glaucoma was
recorded in the EHR but there are very
limited study try to use EHR to develop
the model or make the prediction so
based on our literature review paper
just semion except this year application
of artificial intelligence to EHR data
in autumn allergy we try to find all
study use the mention okay i techniques
with EHR for the eye disease and we
found only two thirty use machine
learning Massa with EHR data 130 was
done in UCSD they try to protect the
need for surgery intervention within six
months and that the second study was
they use the EHR data developed a
phenotype of glaucoma try to improve the
performance of image classifier
so breath briefly summary are based on
our discussion and the literature review
we found there are lake of risk
assessment well for normal tension
patients and the current prediction
model is cannot include information as
the treatment and there are several
limitation of this model and they'd
might have the need for comprehensive
model for glaucoma progression
predicting things currently most study
use only one or two mixtures try to make
their prediction and machine learning
application with widely used for
glaucoma management management but they
are mainly based on image data and the
only 230 used machine learning master
with EHR data for the kernel coma
management so um we are thinking
secondary use of EHR with a machine
learning model may be a possible
direction for the improve the glaucoma
risk prediction or their management so
the first step we explore the available
EHR data in KCI Institute
there are several group please here
include assistant disease family history
patient betas are like age gender or
race in the some ayam instrument like
intraocular pressure visual field change
and include a clinical notes and
medication information as we mentioned
the medication is the first-line
treatment of coma and the the complex of
medication is very important to prevent
disease prognosis
however extracting accurate and correct
in from medication information from EHR
system is not a easy task for example
this is this is two example clinical
lists and clinical notes from the KCI
Institute we can see in this case the
window list is mismatch of the clinical
no to recall
in this case there's no medication list
information probably the patient getting
drug from other sites but the physician
record their medication usage in the
note but not in medication list so at
least as we show in the previous figure
medication this may not be updated and
the patient may take medication from
different sites and sometimes that the
same drug has a different name and the
physician sometimes record the
meaningful change like medication
adherence medication tolerance or the
reason use the medication in that their
chart or endurance progress note or
clinical note so this information may
not be get from the medication list in
fact there are several study already try
to explore the problem of accuracy of
medication list in the Ashfaq study she
found a 25% medication were mismatch
between the progress note and a former
medication list in a year chart system
and links keys 30 20 they found us a 60%
patient had at least one medication
discrepancy other than the medication
list problem the medication adherence is
another very important issue for the
glaucoma and all chronic disease in us
at least 50% patient with chronic
illness have a issue of nom of the
hurons medication under the known of
medication non-adherence cause a lot we
can see there's about 290 billion
dollars in US and this figure shows
several any cause of different chronic
disease so for glaucoma medication now
adherent is their friends from different
different studies from the twenty five
or twenty four percent to 59 percent
and that we as we just discussed the
suspended and the consistent patient
medicate medication adherence it's
critical for prevent disease broken
noses but there are several factor of
fact a good coma patient medication
adherence for example that I drop used
for the glaucoma is for some patient is
painful sensation and they they will
they don't want to continue use it and
the the Oklahoma open angle glaucoma is
an unknown significance impotence and
only the visual field change from the
peripheral can find
so that's make many a lot of patient
they have no motivation to continue used
I drop and a lot of glaucoma patient are
senior senior people so the forgiveness
is a another issue generally there are
two way to make sure the medication
adherence first is direct direct measure
include observe observation means of
drug concentration and adherence monitor
device monitoring device is the most
accurate way but it's called and not so
convenient and in direct indirect matter
include the patient self-report and pill
counts and raise of prescription refill
however this interact matter from the
structure year data like pale counts and
rate of prescription the accuracy is
questionable and sometimes cannot
represent actual medication adherence of
patient so for this problem we we found
a structure year EHR data for medication
adherence may not comprehend it enough
and we might need some way to get
medication adherence information from
clinical notes especially in KCI
Institute glaucoma especially always
recall pretty clear detailed information
about the medication adherence in their
notes
so from the previous literature review
and discussion we raised several
research question here for the EHR data
with the medication information we want
to know how can weeks and take that
quality of medication list since we
found there are some mismatched or
missing problem and we also want to know
how can we get medication at the
hearings information from clinical notes
and for the glaucoma onset or
progression we want to find some way to
efficiently use EHR data to improve the
risk prediction and a progression
prediction since there are some
limitation and difficulty for make
prediction on current study so here we
will start our potential project to
address these problems the first
potential project is predicting
medication adherence of color coma
patient using natural language process
since we want to get the information
from the clinical notes so we are
thinking can we use natural language
process to get useful information from
the notes and based on our literature
review on literature search on the
PubMed there are only four thirty use
the natural language process to get the
medication adherence information from
notes in the nose 30 focus on the eye
disease so this using the natural
language process to extract information
of of medication adherence as probably
is another way to manage the glaucoma
disease natural language processes is
the subtype of machine learning used to
add a computer or the machine to
understand human language and there are
several different group of algorithms in
this study we might use the think text
in a group of thing the origin of the
group of syntax or tokenization that we
can get useful information in a long
tacs
so here is some example of people do the
annotation of the discharge noting
previous studies so we can see the some
some sentence like poor medication
complains to get medicine or fail to
take medicine at right eye or do not be
following the company with her
medications this kind of sentence will
be noted a as a poor medication
adherence so here is our possible
methodology for this project we need to
develop a vocabulary of the turns
describing the medication adherence and
a non adherence and we need human like
physician or researcher to code it the
code at the training note as medication
or now at the namitha medication
adherence or non adherence and we will
use this training note to Trender
language or natural language process of
arisen to identify the instance of
medication adherence and we can evaluate
the precise and recall movement of this
algorithm
our second project will be data quality
measures measurements of medication
layers of coma in the EHR system since
we found there are some on problem of
like mismatch of medication list or the
no miss no medication dates for some
patients so we want to use the NATO
language process each kratom medication
information such as drug nan dosage
frequency reason for use from the
clinical notes and we can compare this
information to the medication list and
do the data quality measurement of this
this this information the third
potential project will be predicting the
certain ear risk for developing prior
primary open-angle glaucoma in this
project we are not only focus on the
ocular hypertension patient we also want
to create a prediction model for normal
tension ocular pressure patients and we
might use some the EHR data after the
patient start treatment that we can use
some major change or a fluctuation issue
so here is the some possible predictors
based on the risk factor related to the
glaucoma on that and some change of the
clinical mention and right side blue and
this one shows the predictors of star
scores so we can remember they're only
age and several clinical measures used
for this model so we hope our model had
up can have a different information
input and for different type of patient
for the no more tension patient
for this study there are several
possible machine learning algorithm we
can use include a logistic regression
elastic internet support vector machine
random forests gradient boosting machine
and artificial neural networks and we
also can use some hybrid model that's
like voting clear viruses and that come
we can combine different mechanism
algorithm to get a better performance of
the model here is a figure illustrate
the basic idea of this machine learning
models in the in linear regression we
assume the input and output data have
linear relationship and we can use it to
make prediction of the given data
logistic regression line here is a
extension of the linear equation
nonlinear regression function and log
just take function will comfort how
comparable from the continuous to binary
outcome based on different ratio and the
another way elastic net we might use is
the improvement of linear regression and
logistic regression it's a regular like
station master so that not only want to
reduce the prediction arrows also want
to reduce the complexity of whole model
and support vector machine is and
another very popular very popular
machine learning algorithm in this Massa
we will create a hyperplane and can
classify the input data into different
groups and this measure can use for the
the new data and try to play them into
similar categorize and another to
example Massa will be much random
forests and gradient booster machine
random forest is improvement of packing
decision tree you can see the
the illustration figure here beckoned
decision tree is a bootstrap aggregation
mass that the original Dana said will
lead to several stop dataset and each
the dataset will develop a decision tree
and we will aggregate all result from
each division tree to get a final result
and in random forests the difference is
in random forests we will get a certain
number of feature when a certain number
of feature randomly from the original
dataset that will reduce the similarity
between each decision tree and the
gradient boosting machine is another
insane bomb as is showing here we will
start from a weak learner and update the
weights and some information to get a
stronger learner and then and then the
artificial neural network it's the
fundamental algorithm of the tip
learning the each layer of in the neural
network well in input and output
information to the next neck next layer
and we will get a final information of
the final layer but we cannot see the
output information between the hidden
layer so that's fine and hidden layer so
that's the general idea about the
potential algorithm we can use to
develop prediction models so here is our
possible methodology for this study we
need to extract the area data probably
comprehensive HR data for the global
coma patient from the clinical warehouse
run the KPI Institute and then we need
to prepare and proposes the data and the
develop the machine learning model and
the use cross-validation measure to
avoid overfitting and evaluate the
performance performance of production
model in this study if we can get enough
data for hyper hyper tension patients we
can compared the result of the machine
learning model and
the Stars core assistant the current use
masa for the risk protection and that
the force potential project will be
predict a progression of glaucoma using
machine learning method with EHR data in
this potential project there are two
possible outcome we can use first is the
visual field change in certain time
period and we can try to predict the
probability of patient needs surgery or
within certain time period as we show
before we we can see the progress
progression of glaucoma patient are
different so if we can predict or find a
patient in the early stage we can try to
make the intervention earlier that can
try to help like patient with the worst
progress to the better prognosis if we
can treatment earlier the possible
predictor of the progression prediction
model is a little different for the
onset the risk prediction model things
the risk factor of the progression is a
little different so I should list the
possible predictor in EHR system and
some chronic disease may need to include
in addition if our first in second
potential project get a good result we
can get this information from the
unstructured data Australia data are
like Lincoln no progress node and we can
get this the information about
medication usage medication adherence
medication tolerance and this
information from the unstructured data
can integrate with the in our prediction
models then have the potential to
improve the performance of the models so
the possible methodology of this this
prediction model is similar to previous
we need to weave thread data and prepare
process data
the model and the trend model and
epilate performance in addition think
the progression is a continued and time
serious problem
so we might use different time point as
our input data to develop the production
model for example in in this figure we
can see if we can use the comprehensive
data before the patient already
diagnoses at glaucoma we can try to if
we can make the protection of their
poconos that we can have a very good
early intervention sorry
so we might use different time time
point as input dataset and we might
refine the time series input data like
visual field change ocular pressure
change this time series data as a
supervised learning problem or we can
try to choose some time theory
forecasting model such as auto
regression integrated moving average
model this kind of prediction model to
solve this time series power the auto
regression in the gradient moving
average model is it's a integrated way
of the regression analyzes as try to
measure the strength of one dependent
variable to other changing independent
variables it's a combination of three
part include auto regression it's the
change variable based on its own prior
value and in the gradient part means
that the variable value are replaced by
the difference between the data value
and the previous value and the moving
average is a way to fading out some
noise or extremely value some time point
so that it's a moving average so this is
a another possible augury
we can try to handle this time serious
problem
so for summary based on the literature
review in a previous presentation we
found that there are some limitation of
current risk prediction model and a
progression prediction model so there
might be a need for a more comprehensive
model for glaucoma risk and progression
prediction and we found most important
learning application for glaucoma are
mainly based on image data and they try
to improve the diagnosis yeah only few
study tried to use the EHR data with
machine learning model for managed to
eye disease and included glaucoma and
then the natural language process might
be a useful way to address problem of
the accuracy of medication based and a
other medication adherence information
from the clinical node and the secondary
use of EHR data with machine learning
model may be the direction we can try to
use to improve the risk prediction and
progression prediction okay thank you
for your listening and open to any
question and discussion
[Applause]
hey thanks wait n you mentioned a number
of other categories of EHR data why
focus in this case so much on medication
data as opposed to the other types in
the EHRs do you just know from other
literature that that's the most
predictive or what why the focus there
yeah it's a good question um one reason
is that most other type of EHR data is
pretty good recorded instructure EHR
they are like sheet or table sorry we
can attract directly however as we see
Dara the medication information is some
problem in the medication list is the
type of structure each a data so that's
why we probably need get some
information from instructor EHR data
like clinical notes or progress node
it's not just easy easily to get a table
and do the analyze we need to some way
to get it
is there any research about data
equality that's specific Tov theology
records as you were kind of reviewing
the literature did you find any and are
there any you know as you've been doing
this work have you found any problems
that are specific to ophthalmology
records I haven't done a comprehensive
or exhausted literature review for the
like medication leis problem of autumn
ology but there are some example like so
this study is actually they they do the
medication there's accuracy in some eye
disease is microbial correct titus
there's a kind of eye disease so there
are some 30 but it's probably I need to
do a exhaustive literature review on
this question yeah thank you thank you
for your presentation I also had a
question on adherence in the topes study
a lot of those examples were questions
of or had text about non adherence like
they didn't take their medications it
looked like you were also trying to
predict adherence how would that be
defined and then your previous also
showed that it'd be like hard to get
like a gold standard list of what the
patient should be taking yeah this for
the medication or the hearings problem
we might not try to predict we try to
create a classifier to see if this note
should be considered as medication
adherence or not adherence so I see
those that we need to develop for Cubitt
vocabulary of turn of medication now
adherence and we need human to coded the
training sample data or notes as
medication or now
so it'd be like a heuristic indicator
that the patient is not adherent rather
than a numerical yeah there's alibis you
need natural language processing
information from notes
so what do you think the limitations are
of trying to do this with one
institutions worth of homology data uh
you mean uh medication pod or prediction
model part well any or all of it I mean
you know we have a certain kind of yeah
referral institution and tend to be sick
patients and you know those sort of
issues you know how representative is
this compared to whatever kinds of
samples and patient populations that
other other work is used so what do you
think about that yeah the
generalizability
it's a always is a problem for if you
perform studying single or even to
institute so especially for the
medication adherence or something that
recorded in the notes that could be very
different from from the different
hospital so um one possible way it's
like we have seen there in UCSD there
sums the some research group already try
to use EHR data make the prediction of
like the patient needs surgery or not so
that's a possible way way if we can get
some good result and we can try to work
with other group in different Institute
interest to use EHR data on that make a
prediction of the glaucoma or management
general
yeah
yeah there's a good question we probably
need to address future value Aaron that
that's a really good question um I think
one possibility is that within the KC
practice there's a glaucoma service that
sees exactly that type of population
Aaron that you mentioned and there's
also a comprehensive AI service that's
more of a general eye doctor and that
that may be one way to look at some of
these issues because they'll both treat
patients some of these patients with
glaucoma but it's a really it's a really
good point I mean some of that can be
done through the OHSU data set and some
of it may just need to be externally
generalized
so especially if you're looking at the
HR data and medications and things that
are specific to
the range of space
nice presentation I appreciate that you
laid out three potential projects and
your symposium I think that's great
could you go back to how you are
measuring medication adherence you have
you listed some methods Oh direct
methods and something else here no it
was like direct methods about directness
yep yep okay so I will just speak from a
family members perspective it feels like
pill counts are actually pretty easy
they have pill boxes if they actually
use the pill boxes then I can say to my
family member who remains nameless hmm I
see all the pills are still in
yesterday's box so it's pretty obvious
that he hasn't taken those pills but
eyedrops are not unless I'm not if I'm
not physically there I don't know
whether he's taken an eye drop how I
mean I don't know that you're gonna do
blood or urine tests but I mean how do
you know whether someone has put their
eye drop in if it's self-report and you
asked my particular family member he
would think he's doing it every night
but I'd have no idea yeah this the in
central problem of interact rapport
matter so if we can use the natural
entry process get information from
cleaning notes it still the self-report
to the physician and physician record it
so one possible way is as we mentioned
adherence monitor device is the most
accurate but the cause and inconvenient
will be a problem so one possible way is
to do external Faraday's daddy like use
the observation or the monitor device to
to compare the result to the if we
gather resolve on the natural-language
process but using natural language
process itself cannot solve this problem
it's an initial problem for self-report
yeah so
there are some researchers out there
that in ophthalmology and glaucoma
specifically that are using special
medication bottles that you can at least
figure out if they've opened the bottle
it's certainly times yeah but it's still
not gonna know if you've actually made
it in your eye but at least they would
know although this is it's still very
early work
if you wouldn't mind just telling the
group because I think one of the issues
in terms of progression risk and using
the EHR data to predict like is someone
getting worse or is somebody December
Lee have glaucoma can you give the group
a little bit of a sense of how good the
current models are at doing this because
that's you know I obviously in your
thesis you'll want to do something
that's as good or better yeah there are
two type of prediction model currently
use one is for the risk prediction
that's in the scores score system this
here and this model was external alibi
fairly fairly date by several study and
the average f score that the ROC ROC AUC
score is about 0.7 is about seventy
percent and the result of other
prediction prediction prognosis model
the result is very it is not very clear
number but the problem of some of this
study is they just use certain like one
or two Mincher and for the kind of
patient they have a lot of exclusion
quite here it's the same situation we
can see in the star scored a exclude
diabetes patient with with you know
posse and the other issues so the goal
of this studies can we develop a more
comprehensive prediction model
so just in terms of you know a point 7a
you see isn't it's better than random
and it's not very good what would be
clinically useful how high of a
performance and I'm not saying that you
have to you know achieve that to have a
decent dissertation but how high a
performance or what's the minimum
performance level that would be you know
clinically useful and you know that's
for whatever that intervention would be
that's based on that yeah there's a
interesting direction I think it could
be a like cost-effective problem so that
means if we even the prediction rate
it's not very good but if we can
intervention for some patients then we
can reduce the chance to blindness and
we can try to calculate a cost effective
that probably worse to do that but it's
a very interesting direction for a
better way for the prediction model
thank you
okay thank you guys